[Music]
[Music]
excellent brand of water yes i can't
read that my eyes don't go that far yes
clap clap you minions but don't look at
me when you're clapping i'll destroy you
blue velvet happy wednesday everyone
so shut up
so where are we in this pandemic it's
hard to say some people are acting like
adults others are acting like children
and still others are treating children
like adults and i'm not even talking
about cnn producers
but first to the pandemic news that's
affecting our nation's political elites
in washington d.c our state capitol cat
strip clubs have allegedly been warned
about their dancers not wearing masks in
a hard-hitting investigative report the
daily caller finds that multiple strip
clubs have violated the mayor's order on
masks this includes apparently the
strippers who are supposed to cover
their noses and mouths even if their
butts aren't
now this is a personal point i would not
mind the rule in the day time you know
when the clubs aren't exactly fielding
the first string they shift yeah
but really how can you enjoy a good lap
dancer if you can't understand the
stripper's story about how she's just
doing this temporarily to put herself
through med
and what kind of mask do you wear when
stripping i had to ask stuart varney
and no they do not make an n95 in latex
god knows i've looked all over pete
hegs's office
but the strippers i bet they're not
pleased we go to one for comment
[Music]
a bear strip club i can dream tyrus
on the other coast it's worse the la
unified school district said it's
banning students from wearing cloth
masks they must now wear well-fitted
non-cloth masks with a nose wire at all
times including outdoors
well at least that'll prepare them for a
future in stripping or smash and grab
which are both very popular vocations in
la right now
but what are you supposed to do i guess
it's time for
[Music]
ray guthfeld's desperate brand to end
this book
here's one thing we didn't expect how
authoritarianism was unleashed in
businesses by our government the
government made the regulations which
put put it on waitresses and hostesses
and mattress salesmen to force you to
comply and then it was up to the cops to
arrest you if you didn't so while the
government looks benign it's your
neighbors who became the enforcers what
better way to unify a nation's people
than force them into the roles of cops
and robbers you couldn't divide people
any more efficiently with a table saw
and i've
tried but you know what a lot of people
liked it
people became okay with incremental
authoritarianism like the frog in that
slow boiling water an experiment i'm
sure fauci invented this sick bastard
they enjoyed the moment without knowing
how it all will end like giving jesse
waters his own show
it gave obnoxious people power
see authoritarianism doesn't just show
up one day screaming hey everyone i'm an
authoritarian it comes gradually step by
step like an undetected malignant tumor
it just grows and who knew that
entertainers and journalists usually
considered skeptics of power would
happily embrace
becoming the man
this is what i call face mask freakouts
you know i i've made it clear i can't
stand seeing people walking around
without a mask this is what we're doing
to protect our families and you don't
have to do it but stay away from
everybody how dare you be so flippant
man how dare you be so flippant it's
also a question of manners good manners
no no no no it's actually if you scare
people by not wearing a mask
and so the rebels have become the
establishment choosing fear over risk
management but risk management is not
just brave it's sensible the world is
not your house that you can make child
proof and you can't leave it to bozos
who see risk only being acceptable at
zero that destroys society you'd have to
lock yourself in the basement to survive
and like i said to joe devito's robot
girlfriend
that's no life
but it's hard to explain this to people
in love with their own authority you
can't wrestle fear away from them like a
vaping pen to cat it's too important to
them the people in charge right now
aren't risk managers they're ass
protectors trying to keep themselves
from being fired sued or even arrested
and they deserve little respect given
they never clearly gave us the whole
story think about it they've been
applying the same risk profile from one
person to the next without any clarity a
ten-year-old skateboarder somehow has
the same risk profile as a 65 year old
obese smoker so they both must mask up
and outside it's like hiring a tax
accountant for your six-year-old who ran
a lemonade stand you know because it's
april and you just never know
fact is the government isn't crazy about
telling you about your lower risk
profile because then you won't adhere to
their uniform rules so the government
needs to have a uniform risk which is a
uniform lie that creates a uniform panic
that's why they never talked about
obesity and other metrics of bad health
they preferred you scared screw them
remember it wasn't you or me who made
the virus and let it out it was them if
it were you you'd be receiving your
dinner through a slot in your cell door
for the rest of your damn life but the
people who thought it was fine to
increase lethality and contagiousness of
coronaviruses in wuhan are now lecturing
us about risk it's nuts
let's hear it from brett
january 27th fauci is told the national
institute of allergy and infectious
diseases has been indirectly funding the
wuhan lab through eco health alliance a
us-based scientific nonprofit that had
been working with novel coronaviruses
january 31st dr christian anderson a
noted virologist at the scripps lab
privately tells fauci that after
discussions with his colleagues some of
covet 19's features potentially look
engineered and quote the genome is
inconsistent with expectations from
evolutionary theory
so when will they be held accountable i
predict it'll happen when cat beats
tyrus and arm wrestling
and now they talk about a new variant of
omicron we could have another variant
arise in the future that looks more like
omicron than previous variants there you
go it's the war without end framework
and so as one variant leaves another one
shows up as one battle fades return with
a new one it's coveted it was also in
climate change it's also in racism
you'll keep paying for an emergency that
never ends and we've seen how wars with
no end game end up going on forever
vietnam afghanistan the drug war sex in
the city
the only way to stop that madness is if
you do the stopping public sentiment
ended those wars and it's time to do the
same thing now because it's not me who
decides when this ends it's you you
understand risk you follow the science
as we close in on february 1st it's time
for some good old-fashioned group civil
disobedience don't wear the mask hell
burn the damn thing that worked with
bras and draft cards in the 1960s and
also the house i burned down because the
voices told me to
when someone asks you to remask say
that's not following the science and
then leave go somewhere else if we all
do this together it ends because if you
don't do it no one will and then we're
all screwed hopefully at the strip club
[Applause]
tonight's guest
they call his jokes bits because the
laughs are so tiny writer and comedian
joe devito
she talks so fast her mouth gets shin
splints outnumbered co-host emily
compagno
she's the girl of your dreams if you
want a blonde freddy krueger foxy's
contributor cat tim
and if you're looking for his house just
climb up the beanstalk my massive
sidekick in the nwa world television
champion tyrus
emily good to see you good to see you
you look uh um you look good in leather
you know not a lot of people can pull
off leather
you should see me when i get home
because it's very tight
how do people how do people end this
right i keep i keep giving this advice
emily but i'm not really giving
practical advice i'm saying you guys got
to end this
but it's when one person does something
and then another person sees that person
do something and then that activity
becomes contagious yeah and i actually
think that you did propose the solution
in your monologue when you said it's
about public sentiment and the public
showing up and standing up
in the way of civil disobedience in a
non-violent way so to the mask point
they're in la in los angeles school
district right so now they have to wear
this certain kind of mask with a with a
nose thing right and that means that is
indicating the priority there of
obviously the teachers union and the
schools there it means that the priority
is not on mental health it's not on the
fact that in the last semester alone
they've seen more referrals for mental
health more referrals for disciplinary
measures more violence student on
students students on teachers than they
have in any year combined and that was
just one semester so those kids have
reported feeling three out of four
uh notions of suicide they blame social
media they blame the lockdown there are
so many things happening that these kids
are in agony and yet that goes to show
what the priority which is conformity to
those specific type of masks and just
like flying on airplanes airplanes all
of a sudden it's going to be incumbent
on the teachers oh this student doesn't
have that
right and they're going to send them
home and they are totally losing the
forest for the trees if they cared about
kids it would be different but the point
is if the parents said no absolutely not
if there was some kind of actual
standing up for themselves that's the
only way this is going to be the
anti-mask party joe
this is like the tv i can feel it i
actually could i could smell the change
in the air either that or it's cat oh
god
i know who's shocking you went with me
there
yeah well now that it's in the strip
clubs i think it's game over yes it's
nonsense that wearing
the only time i want to see anything
covered up in a strip club is if there's
cesarean scars involved
why i really have to stop going on the
lunch shift yes the junior varsity uh i
think what we're seeing here now is
people this is their moment this is
their moment to be a tyrant this is
their moment to freak out and it's what
makes them feel good is to be able to
put the thumb down on somebody and we're
seeing it in schools and this is really
it's becoming child abuse at this point
because i can guarantee you these
schools where rich people's kids go
they're not making them wear masks yeah
you see when we see the fancy people are
out and the people attending to them are
wearing masks and gloves and all that
right it's terrible and it's abusive to
children because children need to see
faces when they're young they need to
have this interaction that time can't be
made up and if people don't believe me
look up the romanian orphanages where
they raise these children as if they
were livestock and the children were
damaged forever now the good news is not
that i know a lot about romania but
tchescu their dictator was giving a
speech and he was in power one day and
it took one person back to yell shut up
and everyone else started yelling and
before you know it he was executed
within 24 hours and those people were
free so it takes free people to stand up
and fight for this yeah interesting do
you care to respond to that or let's
talk about the strip club well yeah i
would like to say there's worse things
to catch at a strip club
that is like a child yes
ask hunter biden
or another guy i know
but i digress yes great point about the
masks but i just
that's true you can catch children at
strip club which i would argue
i'll take cove at any time but um but i
love them
it
what's frustrating to me is the mask is
literally if you follow the science it's
for you i feel like we keep repeating
ourselves it doesn't keep you from
getting it it maybe can keep you from
maybe spreading some things but you
can't keep the mask on 24 7. you just
can't do it you go on the airplane where
sir put your mask over your nose as you
know as you were shamed for it but if
you order a sprite
you could take it off so literally if
you have a lollipop in your mouth on an
airplane your mask's off the entire
flight or until you know how many looks
does it get to a 50 pop now it's 147.
yeah you know so i mean it just doesn't
make any sense and it's frustrating and
you see people's frustrating and it's
causing so much division people are so
angry with each other and their fights
are breaking out and people are
attacking each other we saw that
elevator right from last night so i
think your point is spot on man until
everyone just says enough
it's going to continue to be this way
because we're going to have like 17
versions of omicron yeah no it's it all
it it's like battles in a war that they
want to stay in a battle it's like oh
now we have another battle coming up
it's a battle for this yeah that's what
i feel like we're in this weird game
we're going to run out of names yes
it's going to be like yeah omicron 17
yes covid 19. a subvariant yes cat um
would you how do you feel about masking
in strip clubs
um i think like most things it should be
up to the individual stripper
i think we should all we allow more in
strip clubs yeah and most do
uh yeah it's it's ridiculous doesn't
make sense just like masking kids out
doesn't make sense especially outside
yeah nobody
but nobody thinks that like there's no
way that everybody that's in charge of
running the los angeles you know school
district actually thinks that we need to
mass kids outside pretty sure everybody
probably knows that but they're too
afraid to say something
which i guess it's you know bad in your
own life but it's even worse when you
know it's kids lives which again this
pandemic has done the impossible it's
made me care about people's kids i know
i hate children i've never speaking of
wires has not anyone seen that american
classic the jerk you know what happens
when you put wires over your nose
everything's gonna get cross-eyed oh no
you didn't see that i mean optigrams
yeah optigrab yeah see i i didn't yeah
yeah see
i learned something new every day can't
wait to see the super bowl no one's
going to be masked all right what oh i
just well i just wanted to say that at
that no okay at that one
i think she wrote i felt like no i did
not
at that one strip club archibald they
have half magnums half-price magnums on
saturday night i just wanted to say that
[Applause]
amazing are you sponsored amazing that's
amazing shout out i wonder if it is
truly archibald
we'll have to find out hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else